Hey, what's up guys?
I got this box in the mail, I can't wait to show you what's inside.
But honestly...The contents even make me feel a little bit nervous and queasy.
It's 5 pounds and from a biology corporation,
if that gives you any ideas.
And we'll be attacking this in a future video
This video here is all about you!
Congratulations, guys!
We are 7,500,000 subscribers strong!
In the month of December alone we grew by nearly 800,000.
So to all of you new subscribers who just hopped on: welcome aboard.
Its great to have you and this is getting to be a crazy adventure.
Now to express just a small token to my appreciation,
I went down to the store and picked up an Xbox One S that I'll be giving to one of you.
And I'll tell you how to qualify for that in just a second.
Now before we move on, there's some very misguided people in this world
that are creating fake accounts to mimic big YouTubers.
And when the real YouTuber posts their next video they'll come in
and post a comment with a link to a supposed "giveaway".
You do not want to click those fake links
because its most likely a fishing scam or malware designed to infect your computer.
There's two ways you can tell if the comment is real or fake:
Number 1, if the comment was actually posted by the channel there will be a check mark next to their name.
That means the channel has been verified by YouTube and confirmed to be legitimate.
Number 2, if you hover over the channel name it will pop up the subscriber count.
If they have zero subscribers its probably not the channel you want to be clicking.
So that's how you can tell.
Before you click any links in the description look for the verified channel check mark and you'll stay safe.
Alright, moving right along.
A quick reminder that every new video I post now has a giveaway attached,
you just have to show up in the first 12 hours, click the "secret" link in the top of the comments,
and that'll qualify you to enter the prize of the day.
If you haven't been getting notifications of when my videos release,
then make sure you have subscribed to my channel, rung the YouTube bell
And selected to be notified when my new videos post.
So that's how you show up in the first 12 hours,
that's how you sign up to win a prize,
and it's one of the best ways you can support me as a YouTuber in building my channel.
By the way, you only need to ring the bell once.
If its already ringing, leave it ringing.
Don't turn it off.
So here's another thing that I just decided to start doing:
I'm gonna show my appreciation for your comments.
Every time I use one of your comments or suggestions, I'm gonna clip it out, use it in the video, and then
send you $25 to give back and say thank you.
And if you win a prize or I use your comment, I'll also post your name in the
Winner Wall Of Fame, which you can find right here.
I've also made a commitment to you that every time I hit a new 500,000 subscriber milestone,
I'm gonna give away big prizes like:
Phones, laptops, video cameras, drones, GoPros, and all kinds of cool tech like that.
So I hopped in my car, drove down to Best Buy, and after a bit of looking I found this thing.
This is an Xbox One, 500GB (500 gigabytes), and it's the Minecraft Edition.
That means it comes with Minecraft for free, but you don't have to play Minecraft.
It'll work with any Xbox game; clearly.
Listen closely, 'cause here's how to win:
Pieces of a secret code will be hidden for the next 7 days on my daily instagram stories.
If you're following me on instagram you will find the stories in the top bar of the instagram app,
and they only last for 24 hours. So what you need
to do is follow me on instagram and then
check that every day for the next piece
of the clue. At the end of seven days
i'll post a link where you can submit the
entire code and qualified win the xbox one
the link to my Instagram is in the
description now if you don't have an
instagram account we just don't feel
like to wait that long you can pick out
the pieces because by doing a treasure
hunt through this playlist
it only works on desktop random videos
at random times will have random pieces
of the puzzle so theoretically you could
collect all the puzzle pieces today and
submit them using the link in the
description if you're feeling ambitious
i'm running these contests for you
you're helping me with my dreams and
this is my way of saying thanks and
giving back. And I am making a little bit
difficult to qualify because I don't
want to just give these prizes to anyone. I want
to give them to viewers like you that
aren't afraid to work for them.
We're seven-and-a-half million strong now
Let's blast through 10 million and never
look back.
And now that we're such a large community we
really should have some kind of a name for
ourselves so what do you want to be
called? Random nation, random
army, the kingdom of random... Leave your
thoughts and suggestions down below
because I'm really curious to know what
you think. So just a recap, remember
every new video has a contest, I'm
sending you $25 if I use your comment and
for the next seven days I'll be posting
daily clues in my Instagram stories on
how to win the xbox one
you guys are awesome, I love you.
Let's blast through 10 million. I'll see you in the next video.
Talk to you then
Thank you.
Hey guys, thanks for watching and
remember I'm giving away prizes now on
every new video. All you have to do to
qualify it subscribe to my channel, ring
the bell, and select to be notified when
my next videos get released. The secret
link to my giveaways will be pinned in
the comments for the first 12 hours. If
you like what I'm doing, show your support
right now by giving this video a big
thumbs up and share with a friend
I love you back and i'll see you next time